listening to a film courage women
yeah you know it's funny too because i
had the instant kate rid of every writer
in town when i sold my script because i
was my first script i never written you
know there's a lot of writers he's just
banging it out every day they got 10 15
20 scripture sometimes another whole
career without cell Union so I was
immediately a sort of an outcast among
the Hollywood writer sex but it just
kind of happened strangely you know and
what my producers tell me and what my
agents at the time told me it was just
that kind of writing that just separated
itself from all the other stuff i mean
if you think about these guys in
Hollywood they read the same types of
scripts over and over and over again and
also on something new hits their desk
they sort of you know stand up techno
that will they enjoy reading something
for a change when they when they see
something new on that page now affects
them differently and that's what
happened with google doc